I come from a strong family they've got
this they've got strong taste buds I
think will be good Jenna Ortega channels
her inner Wednesday Addams eating super
hot wings without flinching or blinking
all right Cheers Cheers
that's delicious
that's actually like really good I could
do this all day the Wednesday star
appears on the latest installment of hot
ones testing out some seriously spicy
hot sauce it kind of felt like a fever
dream but Jenna kept her cool and smiled
through the whole thing sweet little
baby
baby wing too easy I don't want to get
too confident
that one's actually good that's an
enjoyable
sauce
I'm really trying to take it in
[Music]
[Laughter]
interesting
guys she didn't even touch her water I
probably regret that I'm so excited
[Music]
it actually tastes like mushrooms I'm
feeling all right
got it
yeah
good flavor I'll take like a healthy
bite as well because I need the actual
experience
it's a bit aggressive something tells us
Wednesday would be proud sanity intact
impressive Wednesday I've always been
compared to and you you signed onto this
job but you never really anticipate
being offered or even being in the run
for jobs like these with you know such
icons and legendary characters yeah it's
pretty cool thankfully fans of the hit
Netflix show will get a whole lot more
of Jenna season two is officially in the
works what do you hope to explore in a
possible second season I kind of want
her to be darker I want her to get more
in the nitty-gritty of things and not
play things so safe I want to continue
down in anti-hero stream rather than
typical hero but first Jenna is headed
to the big screen screen six drops March
10th It's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
fans take away from this movie Ghostface
is a lot more of a scary figure I feel
like we've always seen him as like kind
of a clumsy funny almost killer where I
think in this one he's actually a lot of
the deaths are very visceral and very
um kind of tragic in a sense I think
audiences should be prepared for it to
be a bit more of a roller coaster more
than anything
and while David Arquette won't be back
for the latest installment of the horror
franchise Jenna couldn't help but gush
over her former co-star he is like a
little angel of a person I can't believe
he's real he's an unbelievable man now
Jenna has a new pal on set we share a
certain history
Herbie Reed herself Hayden Panettiere
rejoins the cast for Scream Six a dream
come true for Jenna hidden is a
sweetheart and we all have so much love
and respect for each other they're like
family to me he's working with your
friends it's the best possible scenario
[Music]